bonjour à tous le médiator a été
prescrit à près de cinq millions de
personnes entre 1976 et 2009 date de son
interdiction
et serait à l'origine de la mort de
plusieurs centaines de personnes
le sénat s'intéresse de près à ce sujet
et une mission d'information présidée
par le sénateur communiste françois
autain a été créé les auditions ont
débuté le 1er février dernier et la
semaine dernière cette mission
d'information auditionné louis merle
professeur de pharmacologie et président
de la commission de pharmacovigilance de
l'afssaps
l agence française de sécurité sanitaire
des produits de santé
on écoute tout de suite cette audition
aujourd'hui madame kreft jaïs qui est
donc je le rappelle chef du département
pharmacovigilance de l'afssaps et je
vais donc lui demander conformément à
l'habitude puisque je crois que l est
oui je crois je suis même sûr qu'elle
est médecin et un médecin
hyper diplômés donc si je voulais vous
informer d'abord que vous le savez sans
doute un que cette audition est filmée
et retransmise sur le site informatique
de du sénat et pour être éventuellement
diffusé par public sénat
d'autre part en vertu donc
je reviens à mon propos liminaire en
vertu de l'article 41 14 tirs et 41-41
12-12 du code de la santé publique
vous devez m'indiquer si vous avez des
liens d'intérêt avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
vous avez la parole merci monsieur et je
voudrais clarifier j'étais chefs des
départements des fabricants vigilance
jusqu'au 31 mars dès cette année je ne
le suis plus vous n'êtes plus non je
fais partie des gens qui ont été démis
de leurs responsabilités comme madame
herman je l'avais bien fait noter les
vies mars dernier lors de la journée de
la femme est exactement bon et mais je
suis encore à l'agencé française de
sécurité sanitaire l'attentât notre post
et notre poule c pose c'est rien c'est
pas ce sera au sein de l'ap sable joue
ailleurs certainement d'accord je vous
pensez que votre d'aimer votre qu'on
dirait je veux être on a mis fin à vos
fonctions
c'est lié à un intermédiaire
c'est fort probable c'est probable bien
pour répondre à votre question
concernant les conflits d'intérêts je
voudrais signaler qu'avant la prise des
fonctions à l' agence française de
sécurité sanitaire j'avais accepté de
faire partie d'un comité dé sécurité
concernant un produit en développement
des servier qui est cette fonction
n'était pas rémunéré c'est en carnet
c'était en 98 et 99 et
j'ai donné ma démission avant de prendre
les fonctions à l'afssaps qui cette
fonction n'était pas rémunérée et qu'ils
aient toutes les réunions concernant ces
ces comités de sécurité ont eu lieu à ma
demande un terrain universitaire donc
pas des rémunérations personnel et pas
de pas de davantage en nature non plus
d'impôts est clair vous avez quitté ses
fonctions le jour où vous êtes rentré à
l'afssaps
avant avant combien de temps avant
probablement un mois avant un mois
enfin ce qui revient au même coin c'est
à dire à peu près je vous attendre à
l'afssaps donc en 99 99
j'ai pris mes fonctions mi juillet 99
d'accord souhaitez vous faire une
déclaration liminaire comme est-ce que
vous souhaitez ou souhaitez-vous
répondre directement aux questions
je veux juste te dire que alesi un tank
et médecins ayant tant qu'un c'est un
responsable des pharmacovigilance j'ai
une pensée particulière pour les
victimes de la ferme et 10 à tort
autrement je répondre à vos questions
merci madame le rapporteur effectivement
lors de la journée de la femme en séance
je ne sais plus laquelle l'occasion dans
le débat j'avais noté que c'était bien
évidemment deux femmes qui avaient été
et qui avaient été sanctionnés
voilà vous êtes spécialiste
d'hypertension artérielle
quand vous quand avez vous entendu
parler pour la première fois du
médiateur en tant que spécialiste ou
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
est-ce que les cadeaux achetés ap lié à
l'isoméride qui ont été recensés en 1993
après le lancement d'une enquête en 1985
avait t-il attirer votre attention sur
médiator puisque la structure chimique
en est proche
alors nous avons enfin j'ai suivi les
affaires de des anorexigènes parce que
je faisais déjà partie du système de
pharmacovigilance un temps que les
représentants du centre régional de
pharmacovigilance et l'hôpital brousse
et qui avait été créée 1,82 et dont j'ai
fait partie jusqu'à ma prise de fonction
à l' agence française de sécurité
sanitaire
ce qui veut dire que en tant que
responsable ou en tant que suppléant dit
responsable de ce centre régional de
pharmacovigilance
j'ai participé au comité technique
j'ai aussi fait été membre de la
commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance en tant que membre
suppléant à deux reprises et de ce fait
oui nous avons suivi
les problèmes allié à un futur aminé
dexfenfluramine il est exact également
qui nous sommes en tant que comité
technique et commission nationale mise
au port d'el hamiz en à enquête
officieuse d'abord et ensuite enquête
officielle sur le médiator et là je dois
dire que effectivement pour les
médiators on a toujours cette ambiguïté
à ce que vous dites bien il y à une
parenté chimique et ça on ne peut pas
aller discuter aujourd'hui à l'époque on
évoque mais on sait qu on va s'attarder
davantage à la classification qui est
donné en temps qui est apte et c
c'est-à-dire son appartenance à une
classe thérapeutique du fait des
indications qu'il a à l'époque aussi
bien sur le plan de dieu vivant pour les
traitements de six partis 10h30 à du
vent dans les régimes pour les
diabétiques en surpoids pions non pas en
fonction de cette classification à ces
thèmes en fonction de la classification
oms que ce médicament a été enfin son
principe actif le benfluorex la molécule
a été retiré des préparations
magistrales
parce que si vraiment c'est cette
classification qui devaient être tenus
jamais le benfluorex aurait été retirée
des préparations magistrales
c'est pourquoi parce que reconnaître
cette classification ça veut dire qu'on
ne reconnaît pas la classification de
l'om est à dire le fait que le
benfluorex soit un anorexigène petit
prix dans un segment clé quand même qui
est au rex
donc ça réduit quand même alerté les
pharmacologues et même les médecins qui
ne sont pas il ya quand même là
un problème on peut pas se contenter de
dire le laboratoire avait décidé de
classer ce médicament dans le classement
à c'était en oubliant que par ailleurs
ils étaient quand même classé par le ms
parmi les anorexigènes donc est-ce que
vous niez là est-ce que vous niez que ce
que le maf le rex soit un anorexigène
je ne nie pas qui est le nord qu'il est
bref leurs actions à un anorexigène
surtout avec les connaissances et
d'aujourd'hui
mais je rappelle quand même qui est la
dénomination commune internationale donc
battre le rex et qui est la dénomination
ou la classification atc sont toutes
deux donné par l' oms et que oui ils
sont tout les deux données par l' oms et
que et la classification athés
effectivement peu n'est pas suivre ça a
été le cas pour ben hur règles et
l'appartenance pharmacologique de la
molécule donc il a suivi en revanche les
indications qui avaient été octroyées au
moment dé là mêmes qui étaient celles de
traitement des hypertriglycéridémies un
tank est souvent ou d'étudiants dans les
régimes je suis d'accord la commission
d'un même en 1987 a récusé cette
indication 687 et cette indication d'un
véritablement était régularisée que en
2000 donc en 99 quand j'ai commencé à
examiner ou entendre parler du médiateur
là l'indication d'être juge en outre
atlantique n'était pas encore n'était
pas encore validée elle était elle était
elle était en suspens elle était en
suspens donc on peut pas considérer à
cette époque que le médiator benfluorex
soit reconnu comme un antidiabétique et
enfin comme un adjuvant au régime
politique et encore moins qu un
antidiabétique parce que c'est ce
qu'aurait voulu le laboratoire servier
donc c'est pourquoi je comprends pas je
ne comprends pas que vous considériez
peut-être pas aujourd'hui mais que vous
continuez à considérer qu'à cette
époque-là on pouvait faire abstraction
en tout cas négliger le caractère
d'alleurs etc si jeune de ce médicament
je ne comprends pas j'y reviens sujet
revient sur les faits que pendant toute
cette période là on est toujours dans
l'ambiguïté des la pharmacopée enfin la
pharmacologie effectivement et surtout
avec les connaissances qu'ils partent
appareils d'aujourd'hui avec l
historique qui a été fait est clairement
indiqué le produit est anorexie janot
s'est effectivement aussi qui
éventuellement les produits pourra être
utilisé de façon détournée lorsque les
autres anorexigène senti marché mais à
côté de ça on a effectivement les
indications entre guillemets en tant
qu'adjuvant d'hypertriglycéridémie le
traitement des hypertriglycéridémies
oudin a du vent et dans le traitement
des diabètes dit diabétiques en surpoids
et je pense que cette ambiguïté de la
classification dci et la classification
atc nous a ou ça c'est certain et je
pense que je pense que cette ambiguïté
qui va être évoqué un certain nombre de
reprises
on a certainement on est certainement
pas aller jusqu'au bout de la question
pour se dire clairement c'est un
anorexigène même si ces indications ne
sont pas
celle qui avait été octroyé à s'est
enfin à la femme fera mine et à la
dexfenfluramine à l'époque à sachant
aujourd'hui que c'est ce sont des
enflures aminés qui l on t'a métabolites
et commun qui est celui qui va être
responsable d'une part de la ddt
l'activité et un terme
des coups de feu
si vous voulez est aussi responsable
décès qui peut arriver au niveau
vasculaire qui sait son niveau à bulle
est rookie ce soit au niveau des mais
vous avez confiance vous avez conscience
que cette ambiguïté était volontairement
entretenue par le laboratoire est le
problème pour moi c'est que la france
n'a pas su juste aux plaintes et n'a pas
su sortir de cette ambiguïté est là elle
a adhéré elle a adopté les le discours
du laboratoire et les thèses du
laboratoire et qui était en
contradiction d'ailleurs avec des
expériences qui avait été fait dans les
années 70 où il était écrit et là il ya
une note très précise qui est dans le
rapport de l'igas on disait que le
benfluorex est un anorexigène très
puissant c'est exactement ce qu'on peut
lire dans le rapport
dès les années 70 donc il ya là me
semble-t-il de la part de l'afssaps
un manque de grands dirais-je de manque
de perspicacité en tout cas et une
absence de remonter dans le passé ou en
tout cas de faire des étudiants fille
qui permettrait de mieux connaître les
médicaments qu'elle a à évaluer et je
crois qu'il ya une sorte de facilité qui
a souvent été utilisée a non seulement
pour le médiator et pour d'autres
médicaments
tous s'en remettre uniquement aux
laboratoires et c'est vrai que vous
n'avez pas à votre disposition vous
n'aviez pas à cette époque et vous
n'avez toujours pas j'espère que demain
vous leurrer les moyens de faire des
analyses qui permettrait de
de contrôle et analyse indépendante de
contrôle et celles qui sont fait des
essais ce qui permettrait de contrôler
ceux qui sont faits par le laboratoire
vous avez raison des 10 requis et
éventuellement on n'a pas eu la
perspicacité je crois qu'il n'en des
grands enseignements 17 de cette affaire
c'est effectivement les besoins des non
seulement retourner en arrière ahmed
d'aller aussi loin que possible si je
reconnais qu effectivement d'anna
l'analyse des la pharmacologie de dix
médicaments
on n'est pas allé aussi loin qu'on
aurait dû aller ce qui nous aurait
probablement permis de sortir des
éléments qui est laquelle enquête igas a
pu mettre en évidence en saisissant de
l' enquête officieuse qui est et qui est
devenu ensuite officielle avec le comité
de pharmacovigilance de besançon
pourquoi on a attendu finalement près de
dix ans pour étendre cette enquête au
http et d'autre part je veux savoir si
vous aviez été associés aux travaux et
aux réunions du groupe européenne
pharmaco vigilant sur un dossier
rapportés par la france et l'italie
et pourquoi la procédure d'arbitrage sur
l'évaluation du bénéfice risque est elle
pas abouti malgré de nombreuses réunions
entre 98 2003 comment vous analyser cela
alors moi je n'étais pas associé à la
partie et anorexigène puisque j'arrive
que en 99
une fois que les uns fêtaient munich et
qui est des fins plus ramine et
au déjà enfin la première partie est
presque terminé les familles leurs amis
une sortie déjà de honte honte une
suspension d'un même 1,97 à la suite des
valvulopathies identifiés aux états unis
en sachant toutefois qu'il y avait eu
une restriction importants de l'art et
des indications d'une part et des
prescripteurs qui pouvaient utiliser les
produits en france a déjà quatre ans 95
les dossiers au niveau européen qui est
évoquée effectivement par l'italien
81,18 générerait associés plus
tardivement
à mon arrivée à l'afssaps
et au moment où je vais être nommé
délégué et français au groupe de
pharmacovigilance europe
mais c'est un dossier qui essuie aussi
des très près par l'ancien responsable
d'eads et pharmacovigilance qui est la
vice-présidente des coupes de
pharmacovigilance à l'europe de ski et
moi j'arrive en septembre à 99
donc on suit les dossiers on est au
courant des questions qui se posent
l'italie les réponses qui ont été
apportées par là par la france en termes
de des quelques effets indésirables
d'une part et du besoin d'éclaircir la
pharmacocinétique de la molécule d'avoir
des études qui pourraient apporter des
données un terme des tolérances au long
cours et effectivement il y à des
protocoles qui vont être demandée à
servier qu'ils seront évalués au niveau
italien mais également au niveau
français entre 2001 et 2003 en revanche
les études vont aboutir à petit arctique
mans avec une étude moulin qui va être
rapporté en 2005 et l'étude du moulin
également regulate qui serra qui sera
présentée en 2000 nafa qu'on vous en
tant mieux merci je souris
donc pour résumer oui j'étais au courant
des échanges qui a eu lieu qui ont eu
lieu au niveau européen
mais si vous allez dans les différents
rapports qui ont été enfin compte rendu
des réunions où vous comprenez qu'elle
les médiators intéresse l'italie
intéresse la france un tout petit peu
l'espagne parce que les produits et
d'autoriser est commercialisé dans très
peu des pays de la communauté la grèce
il ya également les portugal qui va être
les derniers pays à suspendre les
médiateurs arabes
alors on note que le directeur général
de l'autorité sanitaire a demandé une
hotte a aluni de pharmacovigilance de
l'agencé pour disposer d' éléments de
réponse sur le médiator et ce en 2005 et
selon le rapport de l'igas les éléments
de réponse transmis au directeur général
je cite sont incomplets qu'il s'agit du
lien entre les valvulopathies et ils
baignent le rex et des cas de
valvulopathies survenus en france ou de
la parenté structurale avec les
fenfluramines est ce que vous partagez
cette appréciation est ce qui est du
blocage ou est ce qu'il ya eu écran
comme cela a été dit ou est-ce que vous
pouvez dés est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler la procédure de remonter et le
traitement des informations entre les
organismes de pharmacovigilance il
directeur général de l'afssa ou alors je
ne pense pas qu'il ait eu écran en
revanche on peut toujours considérer
qu'elle a acquis et l'information qui a
été délivrée aurait pu être plus
complète
c'est à dire quoi ça veut dire par
exemple a insisté sur l'ambiguïté
l'équivoque pharmaco chimique par
exemple
annan
donnons un historique puis complet de
l'ensemble de la problématique liés aux
anorexigènes et pourquoi les médiators
et tana et tana est en quête d'abord
officié s'est ensuite officielle à
partir des 80 des 98 donc c'est sûr
c'est certain qu'il note peut-être plus
complète que celle qui avait été qui est
celle qui avait été effectué à l'époque
mais en revanche il y à toulouse il y a
les rapports du comité technique il y a
également les les comptes rendus de la
dé la commission nationale qui sont qui
sont qui sont mises dans les mêmes dans
les mêmes par à faire en ce qui concerne
la halle à l'information du directeur
général il s'est fait le plus souvent
par paris note qui doit reprendre les
éléments d'un dossier de la façon de la
plus complète possible donc puisque un
directeur général va sombrer avant va
être renouvelée ou nommer tout toutes
les trois ans il est certain qu'il n'est
pas nécessairement au courant des
l'ensemble des éléments et donc il faut
il faut rappeler l'historique de dix
dossiers mais je rappelle que dans la
note s'associent toujours ça c'est pas
s'il ya un comité technique kanaan et
2005 qui traite les problèmes d acheter
ap des problèmes psychiatriques il y a
également une une commission nationale
qui va s'est déroulée au mois de
novembre de la même année pour sur le
même sur les mêmes problèmes
concrètement vous avez on n'est pas là
on l'a dit on encore tout à l'heure
vendredi à à chaque édition plus
peut-être qu'au début on n'est pas là en
procédure judiciaire ce n'est pas notre
mission on est là pour et pour évaluer
la politique du médicament que nous
votons et que nous mettons en place
vous avez été sanctionné madame pour
vous où est-elle dysfonctionnements dans
dance est fondamentalement qu'est ce que
vous avez envie de dire ici aux
sénateurs je pense qu'ils les
dysfonctionnements majeurs ça a été la
l'échangé d'informations entre les
différents commission experts qui sont
en charge de l'évaluation des
médicaments
je m'explique la commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance a pour mission son
comité technique qui est les groupes de
travail la commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance ont pour mission
l'évaluation des risques liés à
l'utilisation des médicaments qu'il soit
dans ses indications voir aura mêmes
puisque ça arrive et ça arrive souvent
cette évaluation des risques forcément
c'est fait dans les contextes de 10
bénéfices du médicament
même si ce n'est pas la mission de la
commission ce n'était pas la mission de
la commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance mais vous allez
convenir comme moi qui s'est un peu
schizophrène de faire une évaluation de
risques sans tenir compte du bénéfice
c'est la raison pour laquelle en 2005
cette commission des pharmas covigilance
pointe quelques signaux pointent
quelques problèmes et c'est dit nous
souhaiterons bien analyser ces risques
dans les contextes dit bénéfices et nous
demandons
une évaluation complète des bénéfices
risques dans les deux indications qui
sont autorisés et cette réévaluation du
bénéfice-risque live valuation des
risques a déjà été fait donc il reste à
faire l'évaluation des bénéfices et ça
c'est la commission d'un et même avec
ces groupes ou son groupe de travail
les dogues qui sont qui sont en charge
typicité des commissions ne donne pas
une visibilité d'ensemble à celui qui
doit prendre la décision édile a dit
blanc l'audi noire donc finalement je me
suis tue en gris elle avant de prendre
une décision penser que les différentes
commissions qui donne des avis qui ne
sont pas toujours concordants ne
permettent pas donc aux autorités qui
doivent prendre une décision finalement
d'avoir tous les éléments pour prendre
la décision adéquate
je pense qu il y à des commissions qui
ont des fonctions très précise à 6 les
fonctions d chacune des commissions et
sont mises devant les décideurs
avec les arguments des uns et des autres
la décision peut être prise
il est aussi important de dire que s'il
y a ici c'est ce qui s'est passé en 2007
en quelque sort une commission nationale
de pharmacovigilance qui demande à la
commission de temps et même des
tesnières bien compte des risques
potentiels du médicament ont vu dinh
dinh d'un bénéfice qui est jugée modeste
la commission d'un mm à la lumière des
travaux des moulins d'un parent va
éliminer au va suspendre une hymne des
indications celle des
hypertriglycéridémies mais va regarder
là l'indication en arrivant chez le
diabétique elle bat s'est contenté d ça
mais on aurait pu c'est vrai également
faire remonter de façon plus précise les
dissensions à quelque sorte qui existait
entre une commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance qui y est allé pour
certains de ses membres jusqu'à dire
nous considérons que les bénéfices
risques est négative ce n'était pas
majoritaire 2005
ce concept en 2050 et ses ambitions
nationale de pharmacovigilance des
mondes à la révolution du bénéfice rice
lorsqu'en 2007 la commission nationale
de pharmacovigilance prendre
connaissance de la partie évaluation des
bénéfices
elle va faire part de ses doutes et il y
à un certain nombre des membres mais
c'est pas mal cherchera jamais combien
meilleur j'ai pas porté sur la france et
verbales hélas non à l'époque on
comptabilisait et les vélos et les votes
pour les votes comptent parfois mais
lorsqu'il y avait des voix ça clairement
j'ai maintenant c'est différent on
procède différemment
non seulement elles sont comptabilisés
mais également si les membres de la
commission les demandes sont nombreuses
clairement mentionné d'année
donc en 2007 il ya eu 2 sa vie qui
n'était pas parfaitement identiques pas
parfaitement y danser ça d'accord alors
j'aimerais vous poser une question
concernant la régulation le la laisser
réguler est il a été prescrit si ma
mémoire est bonne enfin dans les années
2000 quelque chose comme ça et on en a
connu le résultat que rarement à
l'ultime limite c'est à dire peu de
temps avant que le médicament soit
retiré ce qui veut dire qu'il a fallu
sept ans sept ou huit ans pour obtenir
les résultats de cette étude est ce que
vous pensez que ça n'est pas excessif et
qu' on aurait pu réaliser cette étude
dans un délai beaucoup plus rapide
est ce que vous le vous pensez que c'est
que c'était possible et si oui pour
quelles raisons est ce que ça a été
aussi long alors les servier avait
présenté un protocole en 2001 où il y
avait une les volets et cardiologique et
qui va se transformer plusieurs années
plus tard en avant quelques années plus
tard un étude regulate il est possible
qu ici l'étude avait été fait plus tôt
on aurait pu avoir les mêmes résultats
qui pourraient du late si ç'avait été
connue en 2007
au vu des événements des cas de
valvulopathies à l'époque il y en avait
très peu peut-être on aurait pris une
décision différente
je ne peux pas les je ne peux pas
l'affirmer et selon vous pour que le
réseau on avait cette option
une étude s'est enfin protocole n'est
pas extrêmement longues à être mis à
être écrit ensuite la mise en place d'un
protocole peut être assez longue
et l'inclusion des patientes et des
patients également je vous rappelle que
benfluorex était autorisée d'un très peu
des pays donc il allait il fallait
trouver des endroits où les protocoles
allait être mise en place allait être
acceptée par les comités de protection
des patients et ensuite il faut inclure
les patients et avant terminées les
inclusions l'analyse est longue donc
n'est pas si simple
ni cour des fermes des maîtres en
plaçant un protocole pas ce qui signifie
en d'autres termes que vous considérez
que cette durée est normal
contrairement à ce que certains ont
avancé notamment dans le rapport non
c'est non et ce que j'ai dit c'est
qu'apple aurait collé mais c'est sans
repères qui courent ça aurait pu être
plus court bon allez je vous remercie de
cette précision
il ya des questions dans chez nos
collègues pas de questions alors on
continue
moi je vais vous vous posez la question
pourquoi est ce que et là je crois que
vous occupiez déjà des fonctions au
niveau européen puisque vous avez été
appelé à exercer ses fonctions
pratiquement au moment où vous avez été
recruté à la simple on dirait si je me
trompe mais je pense que c'est ça
donc vous avez donc participer
pleinement à comme dirait le rapport à
l'enlisement du dossier médiator dans
l'europe puisque pendant quatre cinq ans
on fait des allers retours entre
l'italie londres paris et puis le
dossier n'avance pas alors je vais sans
aucun raison presque on avait besoin
d'un arbitrage européen et d'un éventuel
en col a recours à l'article 12
d'ailleurs que vous n'avez jamais
utilisé c'était brandi comme une espèce
de
disons 2 c'est pas une menace et un
alibi quoi pour faire appel à l'europe
qui à mon sens n'avait pas à intervenir
dans cette affaire puisque vous l'avez
fait remarquer tout à l'heure la
prescription du médiator était un
privilège je dirais français il ya que
les français qui ont eu la chance de
pouvoir absorber du médiator pendant de
très longues années
comment se fait-il que s'agissant d'une
procédure nationaliser un vous ayez tout
un coq y avez vous invite vous ayez tout
à coup eu besoin de recourir à l'europe
pour prendre une décision qui revenait
me semble-t-il à la france et vous
auriez très bien pu prendre sans prendre
ce détour par l'europe qui n'a fait que
retarder le le cheminement de ceux de ce
dossier pouvez vous me répondre sur ce
point je vous rappelle que c'est pas la
france qui a sollicité l'europe
au départ c'est l'italie est évidemment
comment la france était qu'on voulait
dit les pays qui avaient eu le privilège
de l'utiliser à plus grande échelle
on a participé activement entre 1998 et
2003 dans les échanges qui ont fait
exister grande échelle ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu plus de deux boîtes de la
pelure avec ce qu'ils ont été
prescrite en italie qu'en france non
c'est pas ça que j'ai dit alors que j'ai
dit
la france a eu le privilège oui oui
c'est faut donc non c'est juste pour lui
il y a eu des échanges effectivement un
trait là la france l italie
essentiellement à la demande d italie
qui a mis le dossier sur sur sur table
alors pourquoi ce qu'on n'a pas pris une
décision nationale je reviens sur cette
ambiguïté qui existe des piles départ
entre les propriétés pharmacologiques et
l'utilisation qui avait été donnée aux
produits du fait des indications qui
avaient été autorisés en a 60 ans 76
donc nous continuons à être victime de
cette ambiguïté je pense que l'ambiguïté
un prêt de la classe pharmacologique et
les indications qui lui ont été
octroyées joue un rôle et de de
bénéfices rice comment parce que vous
avez parlé des accords entre la
commission d'un mêmes et à commission
nationale de pharmacovigilance
comment améliorer l'appréciation globale
selon vous de la balance bénéfice-risque
dans l' architecture de la surveillance
du médicament alors que les structures
de décision comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même sont éclatés entre plusieurs
commissions il s'agit pas d'avoir
nécessairement des accords vous pouvez
avoir des opinions qui sont différentes
je rappelle que la commission nationale
de pharmacovigilance dans la navy qui
est la commission d'amm mêmes donnent un
avis etc et la décision est prise à part
par les décideurs donc parler directeur
général il est vrai également que
le plus souvent ces deux commissions
s'ils doivent traiter un prof un
problème du taux des opinions qui sont
convergence et qui facilite la décision
et les directeurs sauf général celui-là
des avis qui sont donnés par ces
commissions je pense que lorsqu'il y à
une des opinions qui sont divergents on
en a on devrait avoir l'obligation on a
l'obligation de faire remonter cette
dissension de façon très claire auprès
du directeur alors un 2007
il n'y a pas eu de notes à ces propos là
mais en revanche déjà en 2007 il y à là
la miss sur les sites de lagence des
procès verbaux des pharmacovigilance et
qu'il y a avant qu'il soit ministre sur
les sites à un comité de lecture assez
est conséquent et qui comprend
l'ensemble des décideurs ainsi que les
présidents de la commission nationale
les département de pharmacovigilance les
présidents de la commission d'un mm donc
un circuit assez est assez large
je pense que l'erreur en 2007 c'était
certainement des n'est pas savoir mise
en exergue cette dissension des façons
concrètes
dalia car chacun a passé ces procès
verbaux mais on s'est peut-être pas
donné on s'est certainement pas donner
les moyens d'aider d'attirer davantage
la voir l'attention du directeur général
sur les faits qui est on n'était pas
exactement sur
sur un avis convergent jeunes avaient
posé des problèmes qu'on a déposé des
questions spécifiques à la commission
d'un mm à la fin de notre commission de
bruxelles général vous répondez pas à la
question pardon de vous le dire comme
cela
comment apprécier amélioré beaucoup plus
l'appréciation globale de la baie n'est
la balance bénéfice-risque vous aviez
une réforme à faire
qu'est ce que vous feriez comme réformes
au niveau de la pharmacovigilance au
niveau architecture institutionnelle au
niveau de l'organisation de lagence une
agence rompant avec l'aja est ce qu est
ce que vous auriez envie vous avez vu
fonctionner le système de l'intérieur
quelle est la réforme que vous avez
envie de mettre en place moi je pense
qu'elle l'évaluation du médicament doit
se faire à l'intérieur d'une même agence
qui lie à des spécialistes du risque et
qu'il y à des spécialistes du bénéfice
mais que ses experts doivent échanger et
qu'il ne doit pas avoir prévalence
dindin commission par rapport à une
autre
ce qui voudrait dire qu éventuellement à
un moment donné on pourrait penser à la
possibilité d'une seule commission qui
s'appelle commission du bénéfice-risque
un petit peu comme l'organisation qui
est prévu à l'heure actuelle pour les
prag qui va remplacer à un niveau
européen
les groupes de pharmacovigilance et qui
permettra à 7 assez groupe d s'est
penché dé façon complète sur le bénéfice
et sur les risques parce que je pense
que c'est extrêmement difficile
d'évaluer un risque sans tenir compte du
bénéfice et qui évidemment si les
bénéfices et modestes voire très faible
appétit risque peut conduire plus
facilement
à prendre des décisions qui
habituellement on considère comme des
décisions dès la dernière chance c'est à
dire une suspension voire le retrait
d'une autorisation d'amis sur les
marchés vous avez dit que vous avez
décrit la très exactement la situation
dans laquelle on se trouvait avec le
benfluorex en 99 vous en souvenez vous
savez eu connaissance de cette
évaluation qui a été fait par la
commission de la transparence et au même
moment on nous signale en 99
un cas de valvulopathies et un cas
d'hypertension artérielle pulmonaire
il ya hélas quand même une coïncidence
qui aurait dû conduire la commission
enfin la direction général de l'afssaps
a retiré le produit puisqu'on avait un
produit qui selon la commission de la
transparence et je pense que son avis
est quand même dignes d'intérêt et dont
on avait dans le même temps deux
accidents majeurs qui survenaient et qui
était imputable aux médiateurs donc
pourquoi est-ce que à ce moment là la
direction générale n'a pas pris cette
décision qui semble découler très
directement de l'observation que vous
n'êtes faire pour quelle raison je ne
peux pas répondre à cette question
notamment parce qu'au moment de vous
n'avez pas été interpellé
en considérant que vous étiez vous me
dites que vous étiez informé de cet avis
de la commission de la transparence
vous l'êtes aujourd'hui mais ce que vous
l'étiez à l'époque vous ne l'étiez pas
pour de la commission de la transparence
et le cadre des valvulopathies et
hypertensions artérielles
mais vous aviez connaissance comme des
valvulopathies et de l'hypertension
artérielle de 99
un jour ils sont passés il y en a un des
cas quel est le cas des valvulopathies
qui passait autour des tables d'un
comité technique mais
et si vous me demandez aujourd'hui si je
l'avais un mémoire en permanence la
réponse est non
oui en tout cas je peux je peux vous
indiquer que le cas de la valvulopathie
temps de de marseille c'est une n'a pas
été on n'a pas été inscrite je crois je
sais n'a pas été examinée comme elles
auraient dû à twitter il ya eu donc a
connu un comité technique de
pharmacovigilance en juin 99
il n'est absolument pas fait mention du
cas de valvulopathie aortique qu'il a
pourtant été notifié en février 99
le délai quand même raisonnable pour un
pour estimer qu'il aurait dû être
communiquée par le comité régional de
pharmacovigilance de marseille en comité
technique de pharmacovigilance puisque
la réunion et mensuels et un chaque
réunion chaque directeur du comité
technique régional fait état des effets
indésirables qu'il a observées dans son
secteur
or on comprend pas que que là que la
lors de la commission technique
paritaire de jeu à 99 il n'est pas été
fait mention de ce vous vous deviez y
assister à ce encore que vous n'étiez
peut-être pas nos wc puisque c'était en
jeu hagadera 19 dans des types peut-être
pas encore à la commission à l'afssaps a
donc peut-être que ces questions cette
question est nul et de l'avenue partie
moment où nuage n'était pas là
effectivement pas s'ils voulaient c'est
un exemple qui démontre que la remontée
de l'information ne se fait pas
suffisamment rapidement et ça peut être
un élément qui explique la situation
dans laquelle se trouve se trouvait à
l'époque et se trouve malheureusement
encore la pharmacovigilance on a vu qu'à
l'hôpital les spécialistes
hospitalier cela nous a été dit à
plusieurs reprises pouvait des basques
et une situation vous avez travaillé
dans le service du professeur ménard
corvol points bien renommée ces
situations contenu de leur spécialité ne
sont jamais arrivés au niveau de
l'hôpital
il est servi c'est monsieur ménard
corvol et plus loin c'est hypertension
artérielle pas hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire
mais c'est moi qui est encore au lycée
c'est vrai que c'est très spécifique ça
c'est voir dans un service de déprime au
logis et c'est pas les services
hypertension artérielle qu'il est qu'ils
les voient en plus ce sont des
pathologies et heureusement encore assez
rare donc ça nécessite des vrais
spécialistes alors une autre vision là
vous êtes vous étiez à l'afssaps
c'est lorsque le benfluorex a été
retirée dit à lire et à ce moment là il
y a eu oui ce que je veux dire c'est que
excusez moi c'est que en espagne il
suffit d'un cas de valvulopathies re
pour que bien que le laboratoire servier
nous est indiqué qui a absolument aucun
rapport entre ce cas de valvulopathies
et le retrait du médiator ce qui demande
effectivement à être vérifiée mais
comment expliquez-vous que en espagne un
cas de value de valvulopathie et pour
conséquence le retrait du médiator alors
qu'en france il a fallu des jeux je
dirais une dizaine de valvulopathie pour
qu'enfin on en arrive à retirer ce
médicament du marché surtout un
médicament qui comme l'indiqué la
commission de la transparence avait un
service médical rendu insuffisant
comment peut-on expliquer c'est
ces différences de da proches ou deux je
sais que la réponse va pas vous plaire
ne va pas même un bon père jacques pas
là pour vous plaire et c'est réciproque
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué je vous
en prie à désirer c'est là lé retrait
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché en
espagne ce n'est pas vraiment en retrait
ils n'ont servier n'a pas demandé les
renouvellements et c'est exactement ça
c'est qu'il s'est passé en revanche
effectivement la valvulopathie espagnole
arrive à peu près en même temps et je ne
peux pas vous dire c'est une hypothèse
est peut-être à l'espagne si le
renouvellement avait été demandée ne
l'aurait pas octroyée mais il est vrai
que l'histoire est celle là il n'y a pas
eu des demandes des renouvellements
parra par servier riche et c'est ce que
je vais en retirer pour des raisons
commerciales série le dis donc c'est ce
qui s'est passé en jeu je ne je ne juge
pas delà de ces kurdes et la pertinence
ni de ce qui se serait passé si lors du
renouvellement servier avait sollicité
le renouvellement alors qu'il avait déjà
cette publication et c'est ce qui s'est
passé également anna en italie alors des
raisons commerciales oui c'est vrai les
produits étaient certainement moins
utilisé que et
enfin passé il était certainement moi si
tu disais qu'en france alors arrive en
jeu il avait un problème avec les
préparations magistrales et les
préparations magistrales qui était
apparemment il ne forme assez important
des consommations de 19 le rex 1 espagne
ni va voir son interdiction que j'ai
quoi deux ans plus tard oui bon on en
est ma passion mistral oui ils ont fait
ça après après en 2005 je crois que
comme ça mais pourquoi est-ce que ce
retrait n'a jamais été communiqué ni au
comité technique de pharmacovigilance et
tenir la commission dans la corrige il
ans je pense qu'il n'est pas consigné
dans la danse dans les procès verbaux
des comités techniques mais lorsque les
les cas avaient été publiés et signalé
lors d'un tour des tables on avait
signalé que le ce n'est pas écrit c'est
vrai je ne sais lequel l'espagne avait
qu'un espagne les produits n'étaient
plus autorisés que cela peut susciter de
la part de l'infa taux de table tout le
monde a dit bombe à l'espagne
c'est l'espagne et la france c'est la
france
vous pensez normal qu'il n'y ait pas de
pas quand on retire un médicament d'un
pays quels qu'en soient les motifs on
doit quand même en informer je crois
tenir informés les institutions de l'
agence française quoi pour que au moins
et procèdent peut-être une réévaluation
de ce produit pour savoir si ce sont les
mêmes on dirait que effectivement il n'a
pas été retiré 1 joue sur les mots mais
enfin il s'agit du cas de valvulopathies
en espagne n'a pas soulevé de la part
des membres de cette commission
nationale de pharmacovigilance une
réaction
notable est particulière c'est à dire
que ça juste c'est un constituée
d'informations qu'on n'a même pas estimé
nécessaire de noter sur le compte rendu
c'est un peu ça oui non peut-être mais
encore c'est loin tout ça c'est loin
c'est loin attend les geipan il a été
discuté brièvement il n'est pas
conseillé dames la dalle nada les procès
verbal mais comment peut-on russe sais
pas mais moi effectivement madame le
rapporteur 10,2 d'arrêter la série n'en
faut quand même que il nous reste encore
deux minutes alors on a commencé en
retard donc
donc vous vous considérez qu'il n'était
pas nécessaire de noter cette discussion
où cette information qui a été donné
dans le compte rendu
je ne pense pas que l'on a au moment on
a fait les les les procès verbal on est
considéré qu'il fallait mettre on n'est
pas les maîtres tout simplement oublié m
mais par exemple pour vous accrocher le
fait que vous ayez pris connaissance de
cette valvulopathies en espagne
qu'est-ce que quelle réaction et vous
vous êtes dit ya une value le petit plus
c'est un problème la bulle pâtissent une
maladie quelques rares mots il peut
graver en espagne peut y en a un peu
partout où est ce que vous êtes y tient
une alerte
c'est peut-être un élément qui devrait
nous conduire à plus de vigilance ou à
accélérer le processus qui est en cours
quelle a été votre réaction avez vous
une réaction d'amour on a pris
connaissance on
nous on a suivi mais je pense qu'on n'a
pas pris la mesure
ça pouvait être bien aucun cas messieurs
madame blandas avez vous des questions à
poser ma la blonde a accusé moi c'est
une question un peu personnel mais sous
les questions incisives du président
vous semblez affecter la situation dans
laquelle vous vous trouvez que souligner
madame le rapporteur de mise à l'écart
d'un poste que vous occupiez moi je
voudrais vous demander dans ces
circonstances est ce que vous vous
sentez injuste la sanction qui vous a
été infligée et si vous la sentez
injuste bien sûr qui à titre personnel
mais sur sur quoi ou sur quel maillon de
l'édifice reportez-vous la faute ou
dites vous il ya eu aucune faute dans
tout l'édifice
je répondrai tout simplement en lisant
qui est certainement les
dysfonctionnements ne sont pas
imputables uniquement à la
pharmacovigilance monsieur pas de
questions
adam crachats ils sont à vous libérer en
vous remerciant une commission et or est
ce qu elle toujours je vois que vous
avez fait partie d'une experte sur les
suivis de grossesse il ya toujours un
groupe de travail sur les suivis de
grossesse
vous êtes une date je suis assez aussi
mais vous étiez pourquoi parceque vous
sur les grossesses prématurée sur les
grossesses par fécondation in vitro sur
les comptes français s'occupent oui ils
s'occupent un petit peu d'aidé la partie
grossesse médicalement assistée mais il
ya une autre agence qui s'occupe de ça
maintenant
mais c'est essentiellement parce que au
moment où en médicaments arrivent sur
les marchés on a des données chez
l'animal et on n'a rien cherchez la
femme et donc on va on va donner on va
donner des éléments de réponse dans la
section 4.6 de caen résumé des
caractéristiques du produit et on attend
d'avoir les plus rapidement possible les
maximums des données qui permettent d
rassurer lorsqu'il faut rassurer ou bien
de prendre des mesures plus
contraignantes lorsqu il les faut donc à
ces titres là par exemple pour les
inhibiteurs de l'enzyme de conversion
on a fait un travail énorme dans les
années 80 ans pourra aboutir rapidement
à la contre indication des leur
utilisation prendre les deuxième et
troisième trimestres de la grossesse
donc je pense que c'est con que très
important grâce villeray unis des
toxicos des cliniciens des des pharmas
qu'originaux et qui s'est dotée d
d'un groupe qui travaille sur le plan et
je consulterai cas voilà c'est
intéressant
les sénateurs de la mission
d'information sur le médiator ont
conditionné carmen kreft jaïs la cheffe
du département pharmacovigilance de
l'afssaps et quelques minutes après
c'était au tour d'antoine vial de
répondre aux questions des sénateurs
il est membre de la commission
information et diffusion de
l'information médicale de la haute
autorité de santé
on écoute cette audition je vais sans
tarder vous donner la parole pour que si
vous le souhaitez faire une intervention
liminaire et ensuite on vous posera des
questions merci monsieur vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président merci mesdames et messieurs de
m'accueillir ici vous avez commencé
monsieur le président en disant que je
n'avais pas de déclaration d'intérêt à
faire moi je pense que si je pense que
le fait d'être membre du conseil
d'administration de prescrire par
rapport à un débat comme celui qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui est un véritable
conflit d'intérêts et qu' il est
important que vous sachiez
en tout cas cette formation lundis de
sorte à entendre mes propos avec ce que
cela représente de la même façon que mon
engagement la haute autorité dans la
commission maintenant information et
communication me semble important a noté
de la même façon que effectivement le
collectif europe et médicament pour
lequel on a été plusieurs fois amenés à
se rencontrer parce que beaucoup d
justement des lois qui concerne le
médicament qui concerne la santé passe
par vous donc je revendique ça tellement
que j'ai été en 2002 et j'en tire une
certaine fierté à l'antenne de france
culture
toutes les semaines a demandé à mes
invités
quel qu'il soit de se présenter et de
déclarer leurs conflits d'intérêts c'est
à dire de dire aux d'où il parlait
seulement de dire wild où je parle je
crois que quand on se maintient ou pas m
soit médecin ou non médecins ça me
paraît un portage à savoir d'où parle la
personne pour l'entendre mieux je crois
que d'ailleurs on le sait bien dans nos
relations personnelles
on ne parle pas de la même façon à
quelqu'un qui est parfaitement inconnu
quelqu'un qui nous est parfaitement
connue à quelqu'un qui va représenter un
intérêt professionnel quelqu'un qui ne
représente pas cet intérêt professionnel
donc voilà je crois que c'est un propos
liminaire mais qui m'a qui me paraît
important pour introduire mon propos je
voudrais dire ici que je ne suis pas
venu pour faire le procès de quelques
individus que ce soit j'ai pas vraiment
l'âme d'un juge
par contre c'est vrai que me considérant
comme un serviteur de la santé publique
depuis
depuis que je suis rentré dans le dôme
dans dans le métier fait que je pense
que c'est très important que vous vous
penchez sur cette question du médiator
et que vous vous y pencher aussi sous
son angle de la communication non pas
que ce soit le mien mais tout simplement
parce que je considère que effectivement
cette affaire du médiator
évidemment il ya des questions de
pharmacologie qui ceux qui se posent
vous en avez parlé déjà ici mais je
pense que c'est important qu'on se
penche tout sur le mediator parce que
c'est une affaire exemplaire
on a eu en france il ya quelques années
le scandale du sang contaminé et ce
scandale a été analysée étudiée mais
probablement parce que justement il ne
reposait pas sur d'une traçabilité des
faits de chacun des acteurs absolument
parfaite parce que c'était une nouvelle
maladie parce qu'il y avait un certain
nombre d'inconnues
ça ne nous a pas permis à tout à chacun
de tirer tous les enseignements
or le médiator à tout ça et donc je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier de vous
pencher sur cette question de la
communication du médicament et que
encore une fois en rappelant à la fois
les rôles de tout un chacun
c'est à dire de l'état bien sûr de ses
agences des législateurs que vous êtes
des firmes pharmaceutiques évidemment
des médecins experts et des médecins
prescripteurs des pharmaciens de la
presse professionnelle et de la presse
grand public mais aussi des associations
de malades mais encore aussi de chacun
d'entre nous qu'on soit citoyen compte
soit assurée où qu'on soit
malheureusement parfois malades en fait
cette histoire du médiator était écrite
écrite à l'avancé ça peut-être qu'il est
le plus criant de vérité est criant dans
le sens de hurler c'est à dire que tout
cela aurait pu effectivement être évitée
parce que c'était prévisible c'est pas
un cas isolé le médiator il n'est en
fait que le je dirais le révélateur
entre une compte dans une confusion
entre intérêts publics et intérêts
privés
il est le révélateur des
dysfonctionnements d'un système
sanitaire dans ses missions régaliennes
de protection des citoyens et et surtout
dans le domaine du médicament
je crois que quand on interroge la
population elle considère et c'est
toujours un problème et j'ai remarqué
dans beaucoup de mes exposés c'est
toujours un problème de lui faire
admettre que la santé serait finalement
un secteur comme un autre et c'est comme
si effectivement la santé n'étaient pas
soumis aux mêmes règles du marché
c'est comme si la santé étaient protégés
que ne pouvait pas y faire n'importe
quoi
et malheureusement on va voir que cette
affaire-là
comme d'autres je le disais révèle qu'on
a fait n'importe quoi
alors comme vous m'avez demandé de me
cantonner à la stricte observation de
cette histoire sous sa sous la
communication
je vais le faire en tout cas tenté de le
faire d'abord un rappel du contexte ou
pierrot tirer des conclusions générales
1 pour leur semble oui je pense que à
partir de cet exemple entendu
alors d'abord un rappel du justement du
contexte parce qu'il est important parce
que il rappelle qu'on n'est pas dans
quelque chose comme comme comme une
savonnette
le médicament est réglementée que ce
soit dans son accès que ce soit dans sa
délivrance est aussi dans son
information donc le thème qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui ce qui en fait donc
naturellement un produit différent que
les téléphones portables et lessive ou
autre pour le vendre l'industrie doit
passer donc par l'état
qu'il autorise ou non et puis par un
prescripteur qui va le prescrits ou non
bref à ce moment là on regarde cette
analyse le prescripteur
le fabricant pardon ne peut pas vendre
directement à son client
au point que pendant 30 ans l'industrie
pharmaceutique a considéré que le client
c'était le médecin tout change dans les
années 70 l'industrie pharmaceutique ne
trouve pratiquement plus de vrais
nouveaux médicaments je dis vrai un vrai
nouveau médicament
je m'arrête pas 70 ça oui c'est ça à
partir des années 70 on en a des traces
dans les bordes et des grandes
compagnies internationales
pharmaceutique où on voit apparaître le
mot de dit ici direct consommateurs j'y
reviendrai donc tout change dans les
années 70 elle ne trouve plus cette
industrie de nouveaux médicaments
donc je m'arrête pas sur le pourquoi on
n'est pas là pour ça bref avec une
dizaine de nouveaux vrais médicaments
par an par décennie par décennie
elle se croit obligé à ce moment là
de copier et de copier évidemment les
médicaments des firmes d'à côté celles
qui ont des produits leader sur des
marchés mondiales donc on rentre dans un
autre dans un autre registre parce que
une copie reste une copie et reste
toujours plus difficiles à vendre que
l'original alors l'industrie à partir de
ce moment là va se saisir des moyens de
marketing de la grande distribution
je m'excuse mais quand vous allez le
copie est ce que le mythe ans et demi
tout fait mais parce que la copie c'est
plutôt le générique oui on pourrait
effectivement pardonnez moi cette
confusion pourrait vous avez raison
j'aurais dû utiliser j'ai toujours du
mal à utiliser les les régulateurs
anglaise mais c'est vrai que voilà de le
mythe ou dira plus c'est effectivement
plus précisément ce que je voulais dire
surtout l'industrie pharmaceutique va
changer de clients elle a changé ses
méthodes mais elle va changer de clients
le médecin à ce moment là ne devient
plus qu'un intermédiaire et le patient
devient client des firmes c'est le
dialecte ou consulaires dont je parlais
tout ailleurs d'ailleurs les
laboratoires ne s'en cache pas je cite
le journal pharmaceutique journal de la
profession de mars dernier
padilla longtemps un titre la gageure
des labos de points qu'elle lavaud n'a
pas rêvé du direct to consumer
on ne peut pas être plus clair
donc si le malade et le client il va
falloir lui parler le convaincre que son
produit est plus ceci plus cela mais il
ya un dernier rempart qui s'opposent à
sa l'interdiction faite en france et en
europe de faire de la publicité pour les
médicaments soumis à prescription depuis
2002 et là c'est plus le membre du
collectif europe et médicament qui parle
l'industrie pharmaceutique mondial a
fait tout pour lever cette interdiction
de la publicité
elle y est arrivée aux usa elle est
arrivée en nouvelle-zélande
à bruxelles on le voit nous au collectif
aux médicaments elle exerce un lobbying
considérable pour modifier la
législation à son avantage
utilisant de pseudo associations de
malades
pour laisser croire que la demande
viendrait expressément de la population
et les malades eux mêmes et nous verrons
que cette utilisation
des associations est un viatique
qu'utilise bien fréquemment trop
fréquemment les firmes pharmaceutiques
et ne pouvons obtenir aujourd'hui
l'autorisation de faire de la publicité
directe que fait l'industrie
elles demandent de faire de
l'information j'y reviendrai mais vous
autres sénateurs sénatrice vous avez été
devant la question de l'observance et
l'on vous a demandé récemment
est ce que vous êtes à quantic voilà
l'observance thérapeutique
êtes vous d'accord mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour que l'industrie
pharmaceutique participent au programme
d'observance on est bien dans ce direct
comme tu meurs mois industriel je suis
en contact direct avec mon client avec
le patient bref avant qu'on puisse voir
en europe une publicité pour un anti
biya db diabétiques ou un antidépresseur
l'industrie pharmaceutique s'est adapté
professionnaliser à cette communication
grand public
je voudrais juste quand même faire une
parenthèse parce que c'est bien aussi de
mettre des images des mots sur ce que
l'on entend et sur ce que l'on dit et
sur cette question de la publicité
pourquoi la refuse-t-on est bien juste
un exemple d'une publicité diffusée
récemment aux états unis et je vous la
donne comme ça images osées donc un spot
de grande écoute juste avant un journal
télévisé image une morgue un cadavre et
une voix off et dire qu'un simple test
de cholestérol aurait pu lui éviter cela
et bien évitons la publicité je crois
que c'est une autre façon de le dire je
finis la parenthèse mais je pense que
c'était important de dire ce que ça
voulait dire que d'entre eux que
d'interdire on interdit cela et je crois
que c'est tout à l'honneur de ceux qui
le font que de l'interdire l'histoire
d'un médicament est une histoire longue
même d'une copie elle commence en
général à peu près une dizaine d'années
avant d'apparaître sur le marché d'étude
en étude de phase différente
le fabricant prépare son dossier
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
deux ans avant il sait à quelle date son
produit sera commercialisé deux ans
avant évidemment il peut commencer à
préparer le terrain de la vente
j'appelle ça - la phase de labour on
plante à ce moment là dans l'esprit du
consommateur patients l'idée d'un mâle
dont il pourrait être atteint alors une
fois ça va être le surpoids
une autre fois la fatigue une autre fois
le mal de dos une autre fois encore le
dysfonctionnement érectile des messieurs
bref docteur knock vraiment pas loin
la publicité est interdite donc qu'à
cela ne tienne l'industrie va faire de
l'information
cela coûte moins cher et cela rapporte
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus en terme
d'impact tous les spécialistes du
marketing vous le diront on le fait
évidemment sans parler d'un produit on
n'a pas le droit et on montre seulement
études à l'appui qu'il s'agit d'un très
grave problème de santé et qu'ils
touchent beaucoup d'entre nous et si la
marque de la firme apparaît c'est
seulement comme le bienfaiteur celui qui
a permis à x ou y de révéler ce grave
problème
qu'il s'agisse d'un médecin ou d'une
association ou d'une société savante
évidemment ce ne sont pas les
responsables des firmes qui s'expriment
devant la presse qui savent bien qu'ils
n'ont pas bonne presse
on fait donc appel à x ou y des
intermédiaires rémunérés qui sont des
instituts de sondage il faut évidemment
avoir des chiffres qui montrent que c
est un grave problème est qu on en est
tous conscients et que ça nous fait tous
très peur des sociétés savantes des
grands professeurs de médecine des ex
champions de football recycler des
associations
deux patients tout cela donc pour
blanchir l'information je les appelle
d'ailleurs et ça ne leur fait pas
toujours plaisir
les agents de blanchiment fin du premier
acte
c'était donc deux ans avant et il faut
bien comprendre que tout ça est
parfaitement orchestré planifié
professionnels on alerte à ce moment là
pour la bonne cause la presse avec des
chiffres des sondages des témoignages
des experts qui font sérieux et
évidemment sans un esprit critique
aiguisé et j'en viens à la presse on ne
voit rien des intentions commerciales
qui sont derrière qui sont pas annoncer
clairement quelques mois après c'est la
face d'ensemencement miracle on annonce
qu'un produit qui répond justement à la
problématique qu'on avait soulevé il ya
quelques mois d'avoir révolutionné cette
prise en charge du surpoids l'apathie du
dysfonctionnement érectile le sida c'est
exact le 6 le viagra pardon c'est
exactement cette histoire là elle a été
étudiée entre par mois elle est vraiment
planifié on le voit apparaître très très
clairement je ne viendra n'est pas
remboursé par la sécurité sociale
oui mais est un médicament de
prescription oui donc interdit à la
publicité donc déjà le fait qu'on en
utilise mais comme un mot quasiment
devenu commun aujourd'hui montre bien qu
effectivement
donc là encore la parole n'est pas
portée par l'industrie elle même mais
par les fameux agent de blanchiment
il ya plus qu'a récolté il n'y a plus
qu'à vendre ce que je viens de décrire
n'est pas un cas isolé peut être
appliquée à bon nombre des produits
qu'ils reçoivent tu n'as mêmes
aujourd'hui et pour cause puisque
effectivement ce sont des mythes ou les
exemples sont nombreux
si vous voulez on en parlera après
malheureusement on les trouve dans tous
les pays du monde
car aujourd'hui l'industrie
pharmaceutique créé de nouvelles
maladies de toutes pièces elles étant
des indications des produits en fait
elle le fait comme
ferait n'importe quel industriel de
n'importe quel secteur d'activité
montrant bien qu'effectivement le
médicament contrairement à ce que l'on
pense est un produit comme les autres
elle le fait par exemple en élargissant
les définitions des maladies vous avez
dû entendre parler de cette menace
extrêmement grave qui nous menace tous
le prédiabète le pré cholestérol la
préhypertension tout ça est extrêmement
grave
méfiez-vous oui méfiez-vous est
évidemment à partir de quel niveau
commence lentement hypertension c'est là
que est exactement là que commence le
problème mais en touche et demi il faut
commencer à s'inquiéter un 2013
c'est inquiétant du fait mater par oui
pour toute raison mais c'est très
inquiétant nous elle le fait aussi en
transformant les événements de la vie en
maladie le deuil devient une maladie la
vieillesse évidemment est une maladie
grave
le chagrin d'amour n'en parlons pas mais
je ne plaisante pas il y a effectivement
ce moment des laboratoires qui sont en
train de chercher le recyclage de
molécules dans ces domaines là je pense
ne meurt on peut pas là traité par
médicaments nous paraît difficile
si monsieur le sénateur jeu peut-être
qu'on pourrait leur suggérait cela
d'accord elle le fait aussi en
transformant les facteurs de risques
réels en maladie sans que l'on dispose
de traitements opérant qui n'a pas
entendu parler l'ostéoporose
oui mais qui connaît un traitement
efficace contre l'ostéoporose
elle le fait aussi en exagérant ou en
aggravant une menace on al'exemple
malheureusement en france alors encore
pire de la grippe h1n1 mais on a aussi
et ça tous les jours et qui est
peut-être encore plus scandaleux la
maladie d'alzheimer
on le fait aussi en exagérant ou en
aggravant un symptôme et là on peut
parler de la spondylarthrite ankylosante
on peut parler de la fibromyalgie et
afin que mon propos soient parfaitement
concret si vous le voulez bien je vais
prendre quelques minutes parce que j'ai
l'impression là d'avoir arrêté est très
théorique mais je voudrais vraiment
maintenant fini vous montrer ça si vous
voulez bien dans une campagne
alors je vais prendre justement
l'exemple de la spondylarthrite
ankylosante qui est devenu le mal de dos
pour le laboratoire produisant un
médicament
certes tout à fait efficace reconnu
efficace contre certaines
spondylarthrite pas tout les
spondylarthrite mais certainement pas
contre tout les dorsales j ai pour
tenter de nous faire prendre bien la
mesure de l'impact de cette campagne je
vais mettre à la place d'un français qui
regardent la télévision l'année dernière
qui était un petit peu footeux ce n'est
pas tout à fait mon cas mais je veux
bien prendre le rôle et au moment de la
coupe du monde de football il s'apprête
à regarder un mal de dos il souffre du
mal de dos depuis un bon moment ce
français et son médecin traitant lui ne
lui propose rien qui le soulage vraiment
est là juste avant que ne commence le
match dans un spot de publicité il
entend franck leboeuf franck leboeuf
ancien champion du monde de la coupe du
monde de 98 qui parle justement de mal
de dos et qui dit même au repos la
douleur vous en flammes
et là je me reconnais mais mon repos la
douleur m'enflamme je vous ferai
remarquer au juste au passage que si
j'ai une sciatique qui n'est pas du tout
une spondylarthrite même au repos la
douleur m'enflamme mais qu'importe geste
et le fou rire de madame la porte
j'en suis ravie si c'est pas si c'est
bon signe c'est involontaire
le spot s'achève par un l'adresse
internet facilement mémorisable que je
mémorise est évidemment après le match
que fais je vais sur le site
et là je vois un site parfait ergonomie
nickel esthétique remarquable et on me
propose plusieurs rubriques sous forme
de petits films
le premier c'est un témoignage givet est
un témoignage de quelqu'un comme moi
donc je commence par quelqu'un comme moi
et donc je vais regarder ce patient est
là un homme cet homme est là avec son
rhumatologues et on m'explique à demi
mot déjà première chose que le médecin
généraliste
qu'est ce qu'on me dit
il n'est pas compétent et on m'invite
vraiment avoir mon rhumatologue on va
voir pourquoi un peu après et puis on
aggrave le symptôme est je cite maladie
fréquente 0,5 pour cent de la population
va souffrir d'une spondylarthrite puis
l'ont fait peur et je cite encore
attention maladies graves
10% des malades font des formes
handicapante
bref on sème le doute concernant
l'efficacité des traitements classiques
en même temps que l'on met en avant l'
alternative grâce toujours au progrès à
l'innovation et je cite encore les
biothérapies
oh c'est joli ça c'est bien ça fait 9
les biothérapies nous ont permis de
traiter ces malades et de les traiter
efficacement dit la rhumatologue et le
patient de confirmer qu il y a eu pour
moi un avant et un après grâce à la
biothérapie ça a été un changement
radical de vie
on se croirait devant un spot de lessive
franchement alors je vais voir le
deuxième film et ce deuxième film c'est
un professeur qui est là et qui est
présenté comme étant du chu tartempion
secrétaire général de la société savante
partant moelle et ce second film
commence justement par une explication
sur ce qui est une société savante
c'est tout simplement le gage le tampon
sérieux le tampon on vous pouvez y
croire moi industries pharmaceutiques je
ne m'exprime pas je laisse s'exprimer
quelqu'un qui va mettre le cachet c'est
sérieux c'est parfaitement fait donc on
a ce premier ce ce premier indicateur
ensuite on a deux intermédiaires par
rapport à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure on a donc cette société savante
et on a ce professeur d'un chu c'est à
dire que l'image finalement du monde
hospitalier public est utilisée pour
vendre de la lessive le grand professeur
continue et je le cite
cent cinquante mille personnes dites ils
seront atteintes en france mais on
banalise on est dans l'indication jeunes
signe d'appel banal et il dit mal de dos
le mot spondylarthrite a disparu le mot
mal de dos on commence à être imposée
et là encore on recommence on met en
cause les traitements classiques en y
mettant les formes mais de façon quand
même grave et je cite vont aussi être
soulagés par certains anti douleur
certes un anti inflammatoire anti
inflammatoires mais attention cela peut
être un piège parce que bien sûr cela
peut retarder la consultation retarder
le diagnostic est peut-être la mise en
route de traitement beaucoup plus
spécifique
une fois encore on va faire peur aux
malades et on rappelle attention maladie
invalidante
mais on ne dit plus que ces 10% on
rassure on dispose aujourd'hui de
traitement particulièrement efficace
depuis quelques années avec lesquels on
peut rendre une vie tout à fait normale
à ces six jeunes
et puis on abat un dernier a tout
remboursé à 100% et le tour est joué de
manière extrêmement fine on a fait
passer un camion j'arrête mais comment
peut-on dire quels médicaments
remboursés à 100% parce qu'il est
remboursé effectivement ça alors nous on
va dire qu'il est remboursé à 100%
ceci au moment où il faudrait dire que
l'on considère la spondylarthrite
ankylosante doigt quand tu dois faire
bénéficier était considérée comme une
affection
je pense que c'est dans le cadre de la
spondylarthrite prescrits sont
remboursés à 100% je pense que c'est ça
doit être ça je pense que vous donniez
l'adresse du site pour qu'on puisse y
reporter a quand même
il est très intéressant je ne
connaissais pas et je sers bien pouvoir
y aller pour faire la connaissance de ce
fameux professeur louis je pense je
pense oui voila je pense surtout que il
a déjà sévi sur d'autres m'a vraiment
très bien il existe évidemment il existe
évidemment faire confiance à monsieur
alcool la panouille pas dû l'enlever
nous raconter des non non non si vous
voulez je peux je peux tout à fait citer
les personnes 1 je n'ai aucun aucune
difficulté à le faire puisque je ne dis
rien que je sache qu'il ne soit la
vérité ainsi si vous le pouvez alors
faites le
alors il s'agit du professeur rené marc
flipo du chu de lille
le secrétaire général de la société
française de rhumatologie
ce serait intéressant qu'on puisse
auditionner je pense on va l'auditionner
prévoyez ça donc on a fait voilà
sénateurs d'arras oui oui attention
oui mais enfin quand quario mélange
toujours d'en pâtir
on utilise beaucoup aussi de professeurs
français parisien a bien parisien parce
que ça fait encore mieux quand c'est
d'un chu parisien donc là non je crois
que malheureusement tout le monde est à
la même enseigne de ce côté là mais en
tout cas ce qui est formidable là c'est
que on a fait passer en un tour de
passe-passe un médicament qui est
extrêmement spécialisé un médicament
pour tout un chacun qui aurait mal au
dos et 250 mille clients annonciez
potentiel et sachant que encore une fois
tout le monde n'est pas répondant à la
biothérapie la firme a multiplié
finalement son portefeuille de clients
par 100 oui je fais le calcul c'est
qu'elle maintient dans quelle forme se
lasser en l'occurrence pfizer et le
médicament c'est le médicament je vais
vous le redemande
après mais je loge d'accord je les en
dci mais je connais pas son nom
commercial et donc pour vous donner
quand même une idée de l'échelle du
passage de 150000 si je regarde les
registres nationaux la lombalgie ou
douleurs localisées dans le bal du dos à
une prévalence élevée qui en fait un
problème de santé publique dans les pays
industrialisés la prévalence annuelle
est de 35 à 50 % de la population avec
une prévalence de vie entière supérieur
à 60%
c'est à dire que en est arrivé à faire
passer un médicament de 150000 personnes
à 60% de la population
oui c'est un très beau coup marketing
150000 la clients potentiels à plus de
20 millions c'est effectivement un joli
coup d'ailleurs si non et c'est là que
ça devient intéressant sinon comment
expliquer un tel budget
et je vais vous donner un peu ce qu'ils
avaient pour seulement 150 mille
personnes et combien question au
faudra-t-il que la firme vente de boîtes
de médicaments pour amortir un tel
budget car je me suis renseigné une race
une campagne comme celle là alors c'est
à la louche je ne vous donne pas loin
c'est ça c'est pas une maladie orpheline
globalement de non je crois pas non
afin de résoudre cette question parce
que le laboratoire bénéficie dans ces
conditions davantage sur ses amours ce
serait intéressant de le vérifier mais
je ne crois pas je le dirai donc d'après
des spécialistes de la publicité que
j'ai consultés on m'a dit une campagne
comme celle ci c'est à dire un spot de
tv pendant cinq semaines sur des grandes
chaînes à une heure de très grande
écoute avec un grand public puisque ces
matches la coupe du monde de football
avec l'équipe de france plus des spots
radio pendant trois semaines plus franck
leboeuf qui n'est pas donnée parait-il
en spots tv en spots radio en web et en
brochure plus un site internet très
performant plus un mix marketing avec le
journal l'équipe
tout ça me dit on c'est minimum sans
frank leboeuf deux millions cinq cent le
salaire donc de franck leboeuf
alors je me suis amusé à faire la petite
division puisque j'ai l'esprit mal
tourné
j'ai donc pris 2 millions 5 / 150 mille
clients potentiels et ça m'a fait plus
de 16 euros le coût contact comme on dit
en marketing alors j'ai interrogé les
mêmes publicitaires les mêmes hommes de
marketing en leur disant 16 euros le
coût contact c'est cher un dia ba écoute
tu es sur un produit de grande console
donc je crois qu'on a la manifestation
là de la preuve qu effectivement tout ça
est orchestrée que ce n'est pas le fruit
du hasard que ce n'est pas
l'interprétation de personnes
malfaisantes comme antoine vial qui
effectivement verrez le diable partout
je viens maintenant à la presse parce
qu'on voit qu'elle joue là par exemple
ça a été l'équipe mais malheureusement
c'est beaucoup plus large que ça qu'elle
joue un rôle déterminant dans la
stratégie marketing des firmes elle le
joue puisque la firme n'ayant pas le
droit de faire de la publicité comme je
le disais tout à l'heure elle font de
l'information entre guillemets je suis
souvent étonné d'ailleurs de ce que
j'avance quand mes interlocuteurs me
demande mais comment et quand est-ce que
tu expliques que l'industrie
pharmaceutique et de telles facilités à
utiliser la presse se sont pas des
imbéciles
comment comment ça peut s'expliquer ça
vous parlez de la presse en général je
parle de la presse professionnelle comme
grand public
d'accord en 1998 avec une sociologue
sophie pillot et avec un spécialiste des
études de comportement le docteur cohen
nous avons mené l'une des seules études
sinon malheureusement la seule sur les
circuits de l'information médicale c'est
un format cette étude a été financée par
le cf sd l'époque devenu l'hymne ps
qu'at-elle révélé qu'ils soient encore
aujourd'hui d'actualité je vous fais
grâce de ce qui aurait pu changer
d'ailleurs je n'en suis pas tout à fait
sur le premier point c'est que les
journalistes de la presse grand public
qui traite de la santé n'ont
majoritairement pas de formation
spécifique à la médecine
je ne suis pas sûr d'ailleurs quant à
moi que ce soit un véritable problème
si je prends des personnes comme vous
autres sénateurs et sénatrices vous êtes
bien comme cela a effectivement prendre
des positions des lois sur des sujets
très divers et donc je me dis que
finalement c'est peut-être pas ça qui
est le vrai problème le vrai problème
est peut-être plus pas peut-être
l'absence de sens et d'analystes
critique systématique pas spécialement
sur la santé en général surtout
maintenant avec les moyens
d'investigation que l'on a à disposition
avec internet il est vraiment très
facile à chacun d'entre nous d'aller
valider une information et pour un
journaliste franchement je crois que ce
n'est pas trop difficile
le deuxième point mais c'est vrai qu'
internet n'existait pas quand nous avons
fait cette étude
le deuxième point qui a révélé vraiment
de façon très forte cette étude c'est
que les journalistes n'ont pas assez de
temps pour bien faire leur travail
on leur demande parfois j'ai l'exemple
une page entière en une journée le matin
alors dit mme fu une page ce soir sur un
sujet dont ils ne connaissent rien pan
sur lequel ils n'ont aucune connaissance
aucune formation de base et donc pas non
plus de réseau alors qu'est ce que fait
l'industrie qui a parfaitement compris
ça elle rédige elle rédige des articles
courts des articles longs elle fait des
photos des interviews des grands
professeurs et le tour est joué
les fainéants sont contents et puis là
on va parler aussi bien pour le podium
je m'excuse de vote étaient aussi bien
pour la presse je réalise non que pour
la presse professionnelle ont cette
étude est largement mené
oui je lé là elle a été menée
spécifiquement sur la phrase propre
grand public d'accord oui
le quatrième point les rédactions
demande alors journaliste du
sensationnel que au sens propre du terme
c'est à dire que c'est du sensationnel
dans le médicament ou la technique
miracle mais aussi le scandale
elle veut du sensationnel et de façon
générale la santé publique n'a pas bonne
presse
ça n'intéresse personne c'est tout gris
ces faits sécurité sociale c'est pas du
tout sexy ça se vend pas cinquième point
les sources d'information sont
majoritairement d'origine industrielle
mais ne sont jamais cités et je vais
vous donner une anecdote révélatrice
pour vous montrer à quel point on en est
un journaliste spécialisé d'une grande
agence de presse nationale reprend un
jour un communiqué de laboratoire
presque mot à mot dans sa dépêche
prescrire voit ça et le dénonce on a
dans prescrire d'une page qui s amusé à
décortiquer la publicité ledit
journaliste intente un procès à
prescrire pour diffamation je vais
appuyer là-dessus parce que ça montre
bien que ces dysfonctionnements sont
tellement rentrée dans les moeurs que ce
journaliste n'a pas vu où était le mal
quand on y pense de façon juste
conceptuel c'est tout simplement
ahurissant
il a perdu justice